- Good morning Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn about
how to not worry about
what other people say.
Over to you, Brett Favre.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- You know, for me, my
career has been awesome.
There's probably decisions I wish
I would have made differently
and as I look to the future
there'll probably be the same thing.
You know? In all phases of life.
And I don't worry about what
people say, good or bad.
We would all love good
things to be said about us.
It sure is nice to pick up
the paper, turn on the news,
and good things are said about you.
And that's not always the case.
So I don't really pay attention to it.
I really feel like my
character speaks for itself.
The way I've played the game,
the way I've carried myself
It's not always been perfect.
But I'm very proud of what
I've done on and off the field.
And, ultimately, that is
the most important thing,
is how we feel about ourselves.
- It's important to
understand that the minute
that you start to do something different,
the minute that you
start to try to stand up
from the crowd and go do your own thing,
that's the minute that you start
to get criticized by other people.
If you don't do the thing that
your family wants you to do,
if you don't do the thing that
your friends want you to do,
or your culture wants you to do,
as soon as you start to lay your own path
and say, "This is the
direction that I want to go in
and be different,"
that's when you start to open
yourself up to criticism.
Cause people are one, afraid
that you're off doing this
thing that's different
and it's not normal and it's unsafe
and so we're going to
tear down that person.
People are going to be jealous of you,
saying "I wish I could go and
do that, but I'm too afraid
to go do that myself, so I'm
just going to stay in my corner
and just throw tomatoes at that person."
People, also out of
love, will criticize you.
Because they thing that your
path should be the normal,
safe one instead of going off
and doing that scary thing.
So as entrepreneurs that's something
we all will come up against.
Because by the very nature of what we do,
we're off doing different things.
We're off trying to create a new world.
We're off trying to invent
something different.
We want to change the way things are done.
And whenever you stand out
you're going to get criticism.
And so, at the start I think it's
one, understanding that, recognizing that,
trying to put yourself
in that person's shoes
and say, "Listen, this
person who's criticizing me
just doesn't get it," instead
of taking it personally.
Because what happens to a lot of people,
when they get that criticism,
is they shut down.
They can't handle it.
They're not used to it.
So they shrink.
So they have this bold goal,
this bold mission of
where they want to go,
and then as soon as somebody attacks them,
the yshrink back down and think,
"Maybe I shouldn't do that.
Maybe I shouldn't go for that."
And so you cancel your
own dream because of
other people expectations on you.
I remember when I made
my first Believe video.
I showed it to somebody who I respected
in the film industry
and he didn't like it.
He said it was too long
and nobody would ever watch it
and that I should cut it down.
And he told me that I
didn't understand how
the internet worked.
And I looked at the video again,
and this was a guy who
understood the industry,
not some outsider who doesn't
really understand anything,
just people throwing
their opinions at you,
he understood the industry
and I looked at the video again
and, you know what, I just loved it.
I loved the video
and even if it was a complete flop,
I still had to put it out,
because it meant something to me.
Now, luckily, the video did well.
The video had 100,000
views in the first month,
it's sitting at over 2,000,000 views now.
The video became the best video
that I had on my channel at the time.
But not everything is going to work out.
Some thing are going to fail.
Some things you're going to flop on.
You're not going to have great results
at the beginning of anything,
because you're learning a new skill.
What's important to understand is,
you need to make a decision
at some point in your life,
that you're going to live
your version of your life
instead of somebody else's
version of your life,
because everybody else has a
plan for what you should do
and until you decide to break free
and run with your own plan
and deal with the criticism
that will come alongside it
then you're never going
to go off and accomplish
the big things that you have in your head.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
what was some harsh feedback that you got
on your business idea,
or in your personal life,
that hurt you for a while.
And maybe by spreading it
here, you can release it.
Release it from your system so that
it no longer bothers you.
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Alfred Gonzalez,
Alfred, that you so much for picking up
a copy of my book. You're One Word,
it really, really, really
means a lot to me, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So that you guys again for watching
I believe in you.
I hope you can continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- [Interviewer] You don't
pay a lot of attention to
reviews and those kind of things?
- Well, you know, you're
always affected by opinion,
but the more opinions there are of you,
of me, the more I,
the less I look at them.
Because I just can't live my life
based on what other people think about me.
So I can't concern myself too much
with other people's thing, you know,
it's just not healthy.
I don't think I could continue to do
what I do if I was
constantly worrying about
what somebody thought about it.
- You know, how did you
ignore all those naysayers
and continue to blaze the trail?
- Well, 90 to 95% of all new ventures fail
so if you just bet
against all new ventures
the odds are 90% that
you're going to be right
90% of the time,
but you're going to
miss that one out of 10
or one out of 20 chances
to really hit a home run.
And I wasn't worried about the naysayers
saying it wasn't going to work,
I just laughed about it,
because I knew it was.
- And you worked very hard at it as well.
- I wasn't going to let it fail.
And if you read my book, it's right there.
I wasn't going to let it fail
and I'm not going to let
humanity fail to get
rid of nuclear weapons
and handle this energy thing.
I'm going to keep fighting
until we start getting it right.